(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Wow.
- [Kelly] I'm very
excited that you're here.
- I'm excited to be here.
I've never been on this show.
- Oh, I know.
But we know.
- Okay.
- And we are very excited,
and we've been talking about it all day.
So anyway, hello-
- Hello!
- and welcome to the show.
- Hello.
- How is 2024 treating you, good?
- Better than 2023.
- There you go.
- Yeah.
- It can only go up from there.
- So far so good.
- Yeah, I love that.
So I hear this, I wanna talk about first-
- Yes.
- 'cause I just got into
fantasy football this season.
- Okay.
- You're into it, right?
- Yeah, I am.
- Do you have a group text
with the people that
you're in the league with?
- Yes, I do.
- Is that not so much fun?
- You're not one of them, are you?
- No, no.
- Okay, just checking.
- I'm saying I love it.
That's so fun.
- Yes, and the memes and
all that sort of stuff.
- Yes!
- It's a lot of fun.
And all of ours are over 60 ladies.
- You find out, oh, I love that.
- Yeah.
- So you find, I mean,
I've always just watched
the Cowboys growing up,
but like, I find myself
now loving other teams
just because of players
'cause they've been on my team.
- Yes, because now you learn about them.
So for example, I had Ferguson.
- (gasps) Great tight end.
- Who was the tight end in Dallas.
- One of the only people
that showed up at our playoff game, yeah.
- Yes, yes.
And I'm a Green Bay fan,
so sorry about that.
- Well, suck it.
Okay.
(Jodie laughing)
I'm just kidding.
You know what?
I watched that game and
I go, "You know what?
You deserve it."
Oh, look at your cheese hat.
You get into it.
(both laughing)
- [Jodie] Oh yeah, that's me.
With the Super Bowl ring!
- Oh my God!
- My friend has...
look, Alex is-
- I love it.
- emptying the dishwasher.
- Yes.
- And that's-
- As one does.
- And I got my face painted at
a children's birthday party-
- Yes!
- for the big game.
But my friend does have a
genuine, real Super Bowl ring.
So she let me wear it for that picture.
- Why does your friend...
What does she, what?
- Her brother-in-law, whatever.
- Something there.
- Something happened.
- That's cool.
- Yeah.
- I would just wanna wear it for a minute.
- I know, huh?
- Well, any Cowboy fan would.
- Sorry.
(audience laughing)
- Anyway.
- Sorry.
- That was sad.
- It might happen in my lifetime.